four astronauts are on their way to the
international space station this morning
they're inside a spacex capsule that was
launched in florida last night after a
delay of more than a week nasa says one
crew member needed time to recover from
a medical problem now we don't know what
it is but they say it wasn't coveted the
astronauts are replacing another
four-person crew that returned to earth
on monday mark straussman is at the
kennedy space center the scene of last
night's launch
and here they are destination space
you're watching the astronauts enter the
spacex crew dragon capsule named
endurance their space taxi to the iss
three of them are space rookies
including kayla barron a lieutenant
commander in the u.s navy
she served on submarines carrying
nuclear warheads but fused space as her
life's most dangerous adventure how do
you view the risk of space flight
versus anything else you've done it's
not about thrill seeking or notoriety or
any of those things it's about an
opportunity to serve in the best
capacity possible and liftoff
for spacex this was their fourth
successful launch of nasa's astronauts
their partnership with the space agency
has reached a rhythm but with the
daunting risks involved no one considers
any mission routine dragon separation
confirmed pilot tom marshburn's the only
space veteran aboard i asked him what
advice he gave his crewmates given that
space may qualify as the ultimate team
sport being open and honest early with
each other will be really important it's
the long haul but we want to maintain
our happiness and our health and come
back as friends even after six months
this crew this launch sets a new
milestone with these four astronauts now
more than 600 people have ever been to
space and by dinner time tonight this
crew will be living in their new home
for the next six months
gail
that's so cool mark something to think
about something tells me they will come
back as friends in six months i love
kayla's attitude good to see you